-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
House Republicans voted toda
to remove GOP conference chair
Liz Cheney from
her leadership position,
but they're already claiming
it never happened.
After Congresswoman Liz Cheney
was voted out
of her leadership position
former President Trump
mocked her on his website,
saying, "I look forward
to soon watching her
as a paid contributor
on CNN or MSDNC,"
said the business genius
who calls into Fox News
every day for free.
Liz Cheney told reporters toda
that she plans to do
everything she can to make sur
former President Trump
"never gets anywhere near
the Oval Office."
Oh, you know what you could do
Elect him.
Former President Trump's
acting Defense Secretary
Christopher Miller
testified today before Congres
about the Pentagon's respons
to the January 6th
Capitol attack
and said he was concerned
that sending troops
would make it look like
a military coup,
as opposed to what
it did look like --
Free Donut Day at the
Krispy Kreme in Middle Earth
A rare deep-sea creature
called a Pacific Football Fish
washed up on a Southern
California beach last week
and it already has
a Netflix special.
Kentucky Derby winner
Medina Spirit
will be allowed to compete
this weekend in the Preaknes
despite failing a drug test.
The horse will be in stall 6
next to
my middle school bus driver.
According to a new survey,
people in the Northeast
were the most likely to use Zoom
to communicate
a pandemic breakup.
In fact, they even
made it a feature.
A Swedish robotics company
recently unveiled
a battery-operated glove
that can protect factory workers
from chronic injury caused
by repetitive manual tasks
"Tell me more,"
said teenage boys.
famously a catchphrase
of our nation's teenagers.
"Tell me more."
And finally,
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
announced plans this week
to roll out pop-up
coronavirus vaccination site
at trains and subway stations,
because you're not
a real New Yorker
until you've been poked
by a needle on the subway.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.